[Music]
Chrissy Teigen and John Legend have a
full house with baby number three I just
don't feel like anybody regrets having
too many kids I'll say the source tells
E.T how the family's doing with their
newest edition SD Maxine Stevens giving
so much to your children and seeing them
embrace it and grow from how much love
and kisses and tension and affection
they get it can be so amazing Chrissy
and John welcome to babysd January 13th
and our source says the two are doing
incredible quote this is such an
exciting time for them as a couple and
as a family they love being parents and
are thrilled to be able to expand their
family I know it sounds silly if you
don't have kids but they say Mom and Dad
all the time but it's weird when they
know that you're the mama and you're the
daddy and you're that it's it's just
different it's beautiful and Chrissy's
sharing tons of snapshots with the
little one and her siblings miles and
Luna
172 107 74. yeah it seems like miles
can't get enough of counting for his
little sis and no surprise the kiddos
love her a source tells E.T miles and
Luna are so happy to have SD home and
already adore her they're both old
enough to understand what it means to
have a new sibling and it's been great
are they prepared to be big big siblings
Luna really is so nurturing and so
loving and so
she's just very very excited miles is
you know not going to be the baby
anymore so I think he we spend a lot
more time like with him and telling him
that he's always going to be our baby
boy and he's like you know he's that's
it for us so I mean he's gonna be the
best Chrissy announced she and John were
expecting their third child in August
with this sweet snap of her baby bump SD
is a rainbow baby for the family Chrissy
suffered a devastating late-term
pregnancy loss in 2020. she wrote in
part I don't think I'll ever walk out of
an appointment with more excitement than
nerves but so far everything is perfect
and beautiful and I'm feeling hopeful
and amazing it's so good and now SD is
here and her name is just as special as
she is SD means star so now they have
Luna which means Moon and SD for Star
our source says it's a really wonderful
time for everyone
[Music]
thank you